[Music]
again was a secular hi Samuel leaves
here and in this video this is a very
special video I've had a lot of requests
recently because people that buy HMO
properties their bottom up north or they
buy deals whether they buy them through
us or or associated companies or they
find them off the back of the training
they'll often say hey I've just bought
this house this will be the return on
investment or these are the figures and
sometimes people say to me Samuel
can you bring someone back maybe six
months later and then get a real account
of the figures so we've got a guy with
us today his name is Mark he's bought at
HMO actually through our our sourcing
company so mark thanks so much for
coming down not a problem at all it's
good to be here
yeah so how did you first get in touch
with myself so I like many people found
you on YouTube I started watching a bit
of your stuff I bought your book and
then I had some money and I just wanted
to get straight in so I phoned up your
sourcing company and I I went straight
in and bought the first deal that came
through to be honest right so you just
ya realize I can always go and we did do
a video of us going around the house the
day you got the keys yeah and you were
happy yep totally I mean you kind of did
everything by the book literally buy my
book because you're a businessman now no
but you bought it without feelings you
didn't know the area super well no
properties in the area
it's up north yeah and you just bought
it yeah kind of blind completely blind
so why did you
put down what was the sourcing you paid
us a couple grand or whatever it was
round 303 in hot brown so why would you
pay three and a half thousand pounds
over in faith I mean it was it because
you'd read the book or what was it I
mean I've done business with a lot of
people everything that the company was
saying made sense I had a conversation
with a guy called Elliot
he was really good taught me through the
process it all makes perfect sense to me
and and the reality is three and a half
thousand pounds to pay someone to do all
of that work for me is good value for
money really yeah so yeah I I didn't
really feel that nervous about it was a
little bit there you know you never
really know yeah I haven't been twenty
or crash courses I'm now booked on one
so finally yeah you've got the other way
around
oh yes I'll be coming along but I just
felt that all made sense and when the
figures all make sense it's time to take
some action yeah and if you if you wait
opportunity passes you by
do you remember what return on
investment we were telling you it would
likely to achieve I think is 25 to 30
percent so we said excuse somewhere
between 25 30 Sandhya so tell us what
happened and so you've I mean we've
already done video one where people
you've kind of gone through the process
you've we've been around the house this
is video two so in video one remind me
of what we were thinking and where we
were up just so we thought that we would
get 1,500 pounds a month in rent
actually when I bought it from Elliot he
was saying 1,400 pounds a month 350 per
room yeah and we managed to get a little
bit more so we've got three settle five
per room that was slightly because we
went for a better I would say a better
higher spec of decoration we had
painters and we made sure that we put a
feature wall in we got good new theater
in we've got art on the wall yeah we did
some other nice little things like we
got a TV on the wall in the how much did
you spend on the total refurb total
refurb including furniture and
everything else yeah be around nine ten
thousand nine ten thousand pounds which
is not a massive amount including firm
and when we spoke I said I wasn't going
to do the bathroom yeah I ended up doing
the bathroom sure you did it 800 quid
well yeah good sourcing company is
selling a property
they should be always a little bit more
conservative rather than optimist so
instead of saying oh you'll probably get
about 400 it's better to say 350 yeah
and then you end up getting 375 I mean
that was our market research we had we
had done an advert when we bought the
property just to see what we know what
that's so good you did that because
although you've paid somebody to find
the property for you and to do all the
research you're still buying it yeah
it's still gonna be you out 100 sir it's
not my house or Elliot's house
Alistair's house it's your house so you
did a lot of market research and then
you were comfortable that yeah I
wouldn't say a lot I did son okay I feel
an advert up and I let it run for about
four hours and had four or five
inquiries that's a credible that's that
was enough and also when you do market
research it's funny because it's really
important especially when you're buying
HMO that you don't ring up single that
letting agents know you've got to speak
to the right or the right team sometimes
people get scared off because they hear
something negative but the person that's
talking is completely unqualified to say
so you bought it yeah you brick we
predicted that you do you refurb and the
refurb might take I don't know a couple
months on the bit say it took a refurb
and letting fully know do tell me the
real oh just refurb about two weeks so
the refocus two weeks to our doors new
fire alarm and there's a couple of
things we didn't know about so we had to
put a new fuse board in okay I had an
old fuse border and we got safety
certificate for the electrics yeah
that's an extra four hundred fifty quid
okay it was a few little things like
yeah and then so that took about two or
three weeks to or three weeks how long
what's the refurb was done did it take
to get four people paying twenties to
week two weeks that's good - that's good
so two weeks and you were to get their
deposits the last one only moved in
about a week ago
sure so from actually being fully left
with people in it it was probably out
five weeks yeah that's two weeks to get
over deposits sure so some of them had
to put notice on another house yeah yeah
it's cool area you know a little bit
more in voids but no much not much yeah
so tell us then so you're now renting
out for approximately 1,500 pounds a
month 14750 14750
you invested about nine just over nine
grand for the complete refurb what are
the costs did you put down
there's obviously legal stamp duty what
else was there
legal stamp duty refurb that was oh and
then once we had our first tenant in we
found out there's a small leak from from
the roof and unfortunately that was
1,400 pounds so a lot bigger than we
thought it was going to be when we first
found them li yeah
but that's now done they've gone a
10-year warranty that re fell to the
roof yeah you know what I'm holding this
my exit strategies death I'm holding
this forever it doesn't really matter
now 1,400 emily has month's rent right
and that is one other thing it's the
first month's rent and that is one of
the things that happen in property
sometimes there are costs you need
contingency in there I've put 10% of my
rent aside for weekend because it
happens but then at the same time you
property goes up in value you get
anything from it every month so what
with all being said including the roof
which we didn't expect yeah and
everything what is your return on
investment figure 27.4% 27.4% which is
nine point four so it's still bang on in
the body of what we said yeah it would
have been thirty it went 30
yeah or close - which means that after
just in the four years you've made all
your money back yeah your property's
likely to increase in value
it already has I mean we started this
journey with you about a year ago
because there were some issues with the
vendor it took a long time another house
has sold recently on the same Road in
worse condition for about 10% more than
we bought this for Wow so we think this
already increased in value and actually
we're looking forward to remortgaging
and refinancing and extracting some of
that value back out when are you
planning on doing that probably in the
next six to twelve months
yeah yeah incredible yeah pulling some
of your money out I think we'll get all
of it out do you really I do that'll be
nice or at least most of it we've done a
good job on the refurb yeah and I had
some really good contractors in to do
that so incredible really happy so in
that case it's not going to take four
years to get your money back no no no
not at all and then giving you an income
what's the profit you're making each
month profits about nine hundred and
twenty pounds nine twenty a month what
was something that a few people asked
from the last video okay
was your mortgage pain
are so so cheap yeah you briefly
explained it on the video but people
were very unsure of how that works I
know you're always yeah my mortgage
payment wasn't actually as cheap as I
thought it was I misquote you died I
think I said something like 96 pounds
yes a hundred and twenty-eight pounds
okay but it's very lucky it's 1.69 so
how on earth are you paying less than
two percent interest on an alternate
property what length no idea what LO did
you go up we are with Birmingham Michos
I'm not sure but I tell you what though
what I do know is that I've recently
bought the thing is did you go with the
growth with are you in touch with yes
that's the thing you know what sometimes
if you turn a light on yeah you know
that the light will come on yeah this is
switch it comes on yeah you don't
understand this you might but I don't
you don't necessarily under understand
how it works
yeah you just know that if you do this
the light comes on some people I see
come into my training programmes or
they're looking at buying a property
they're trying to figure out everything
yeah before I make a single move so I'll
say you know what interest rates and how
and how does this look what's this and
the bottom line is just speak to a good
broker just have a good power team
together and then take the absolute
faith and just with some basic maths you
know that with a hundred thousand pound
loan every percent is going to be one
grant yeah right yeah like we're not
talking big amounts of money so you know
in stress test these properties
certainly with the formula that you
teach you can stress test them quite
high before they become lost making yeah
so I just interest rates aren't a thing
I mean not for me
yeah and everything the Bank of England
is saying as you know I am I am quite
into my finances yeah everything Mark
Carney's saying is expect a new normal
around half the long term normal so that
is less than 2.5% explain that please so
he recently came out and said you expect
the new long term normal to be less than
half the previous long term normal when
you released me when he put out with a
two point where who did Mark Carney but
government Bank England okay
so we're not expecting in the next
years any rate rises above 2.5% I did
know I did a video on this recently and
basically said that you can fix interest
rates up to 10 years and I think it's
not I always quote something like four
point something percent yeah who's
expecting it to go above that
yeah no exactly but then people use that
as an excuse not to buy these everything
does an excuse not to take action not to
change that I one thing I'd say to all
those people somebody who does take
action somebody who is enjoying the the
fruits of investing my absolute you love
and busting um I think saving is for
mugs
investing is is where the money is yeah
and it's just so liberating to see the
money roll in when you're doing nothing
towards it and I recently worked out
what I earn per hour even when I sleep
per month yeah I'm not gonna say it on
camera but yeah it's really reassuring
to know that while you're asleep are
still earning yeah really well well
right now people might be able to cents
I mean a little bit of pain with my oh
yeah with my leg but while I was in the
hospital in Uganda with my wife at home
unable to do anything having to pay for
operations knowing that I've got a
passive income coming in I'd have to
worry about money he's incredible for
you it was life-saving wasn't it yeah it
was like the reality yeah the reality is
if you didn't have that passive income
then your situation could be so much
worse yep trope twist no that's quite
humbling as well I think yeah yeah back
to your house different HMOs are
changing quite a lot yes there's certain
areas that are becoming a little bit
saturated yes
the rules are getting stricter but you
were not affected by that
no because yours was there how many
bedrooms four bedroom four bed so
there's no live stream yeah you've
turned into a full bed so there was no
license needed no article for in that
part of the area and it's in Sheffield
right field which is fantastic so if
your cuz I know you're planning on
buying a lot more yeah what's your
strategy going to be looking like in the
future I think it's it's hard to
second-guess where everything's going
long-term I think I think for me I
believe that the HMO market will remain
strong yeah it's where the value is for
the for the end consumer I think people
struggle especially when they're young
to afford to rent a full house and why
would you want to you be lonely anyway I
know when I moved to lung
first time I rented a four-bedroom house
and there was four of us sharing yeah
and we had a great time there I I
wouldn't have wanted to have that
experience any other way so I think for
me my strategy will continue to be
buying at this end of the market but
making sure I do a good renovation
making sure I do a good quality
furniture you could have spent you could
have spent 3 grand instead of 9 grand
and then differentiated and short cut
everything there's 300 adverts for spare
rooms in Sheffield yeah I needed mine to
look like it was the best yeah and that
didn't mean I needed to do 5,000 pound
bathrooms yeah that means I needed to
buy a 50 pounds piece of art for the
wall yes and that's where the value is
yeah and for me my differentiating was
by making sure I planned out the
renovation correctly brilliant and I've
now got a team who are going to do that
for me because you're a big thinker yeah
so you do everything you don't do
anything by half what tell me lip about
your business background so I've done
quite a few things I my background is
probably recruitment marketing sales
yeah so I'm I've run my own recruitment
business an online marketing business
more recently I've got a fairly large
ground transportation business which I'm
involved in and a few other projects
that are going on at the moment so yeah
I've got quite a varied and rounded
business background if you like but
mostly around looking for opportunity to
create value and I think the reason that
the HMO market is so strong and such a
good business model is that you take
product that a new create add value to
it that's the whole definition of how
you create wealth is by adding value
that's when you take something you add
value you do it to the specification
that your clients want and by calling
them tenants and the US landlords I
think it's a little bit wrong it makes
it feel a bit wrong refers them all as
clients and suddenly you realise that
actually you're the business owner
they're the client yeah provide them
with the service that they expect and
the house is the product yeah yeah the
house is the product so if you build a
crappy product you're not going to have
many customers right yeah exactly you
build a good product and I think it was
our jelly hire that said a dog kennel
will attract dogs right you know you
want to make sure that salutely and you
can overdo it and you can spend
you can unnecessarily area I could have
done a new kitchen three grand new
bathroom six grand I could have gone top
spec but this is a hundred grand house
yeah that would be unproportional yeah I
could have remodeled the garden I could
have made it fantastic but that's not
actually when I did my market research
that's not what people were buying
people were buying the properties that
looked good yeah and we're in good
condition and came with little things
like I mean I've got in there a monthly
cleaner which doesn't cost me an awful
lot but it means I've got someone
looking at the property making sure that
it's maintained to a high standard and
any manufactured you've factored all
that into the return on investment yeah
yeah yeah small it's quite a small cost
but then but then 1,500 pound a month or
1475 yeah on a 100 grand house is not
bad strong run it is long run I've got
I've got a property in London which is
three hundred and seventy five thousand
and that rents out for 1,100 pounds a
month incredible so it's it's less rent
and it's three times the price more than
yeah yeah yeah incredible so what
lessons have you learned then from
buying this property talking with me and
everything you've done okay so the
lessons it's not really anything I
didn't really know because I would
always have budget for a contingency but
I guess for most people they're not
budgeting your contingency or they're
going in going how cheap can I do this
yeah I think that's a really dangerous
place to be starting from because you
need to be able to finish the project
and you need to be able to rent it out
yeah so yeah I think having contingency
is one of the one of the biggest thing
and by that you just mean having a
buffer if things don't go up in the
ground you know we're not talking we're
not talking ten thousand yes I can
imagine somebody getting to that point
and going I haven't got the money also I
think it's a problem having a couple of
grand is fantastic to begin with but I
also think it's really born with with
the monthly income you could very easily
just say my bills and my mortgage
payments are X therefore everything
that's left is mine I think it's really
important to leave a little before each
month oh absolutely
or if things don't go right and you've
got to take with property you've got to
take the good and the bad yeah mostly it
is good there are some bad if you just
focus on just the bad oh I had a bad
tenant Oh then you become a crap magnet
yeah and then the bad starts becoming
yeah yeah but if you just say okay on
the game cashflow 101
you played it happen all night brilliant
cosplay 101 invented by Robert Kiyosaki
sometimes you roll the dice in you land
and I do dad
write and a doodad is just an expense it
just me and say you need to pay the
government or whatever X amount of money
and it trains your brain to just go oh
it should do that okay
there's nothing you can do about it you
just got to pay it and then move on with
the game would you say no absolutely
absolutely
III think you've got these expensive the
one thing that I've learned as an
investor is that my income is probably
trebled over the last 12 months yeah but
my expenses have stayed the same
brilliant and you know I don't really
bad life I live a very comfortable life
but I've been very much I've been
enjoying investing and I think when your
passion is creating wealth he then
actually you can you can do it really
quickly yeah brilliant and you also you
bought the property are you gonna be
buying more houses up north more
maturely absolutely we've got offers out
on two more right now well in geoff
field oh yeah one of them is accepted
all good all done yeah that one we're
just getting the mortgage sorted out on
I also think is why sometimes the people
watching this might the ol Sheffield is
to call by Harriette no it's anywhere I
mean anywhere my product I mean the
reason I would now do Sheffield and that
is that I've got one there it makes
sense and I've got my relationships
there and your power deepen and if
you're starting out from scratch it can
be anywhere yeah in fact if I was
starting out from scratch I might not
picture field yeah do anything if you
only picked Sheffield because you just
happen to have that opportunity come
across you it's a little bit more
expensive than over yeah there's an
article for just down the road that it's
got some problems there's a lot of
issues with working yeah actually I if I
was doing it again I might not picture
field yeah but so true while I've got my
power team there and she said and I've
got people that I trust that you
invested in it each invest in new stuff
on their own goblin area yeah there's
not one magnet on one area I mean for me
I'm investing a lot in the Midland steel
over certain areas and that's great and
I assume I know you did but you bought
through a company yes so you're saving
on the tax really yeah and if you
reinvest the profits into another asset
then there's no corporation tax to play
yeah of course you can start to scale up
and multiply that up by buying tax
efficient love that and I think that's
one of the things that actually
if people go and look at a compound
interest calculator and go actually if I
reinvest my profits rather than
declaring them as profit and taking a
dividend and look at how quickly that
adds up yeah
and that's how you can create more
wealth quickly oh so true and people ask
me a lot about specialist mortgage
advice and ask me for tax advice listen
like you mean you've got what if I to
give that you've been given advice by
your tax accountant you introduce you to
it to my broker he got you the best the
best thing to do is and I'm sure you'd
agree just get a good Power Team get a
good broker get a good accountant get
them in your team you don't employ them
you just pay them per transaction yeah
so fantastic I mean it's the old adage
with insurance it seems expensive until
you need it yeah
an accountant seems really expensive
until he saves you all that money of
course and if you're buying multiple
properties all in the first instance
yeah I'll say you anything for the last
two or three years but is then it comes
in big lumps like that yeah excellent
well I'm really grateful that you've
come back back down to the offices just
to share your story and it's been great
catching up you say so thank you so much
for coming out in Brillion and I wish
you all the best you Jonah
really thank you so much thank you so
much for watching if you benefited from
that video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens but whatever
you do don't forget to subscribe right
here and I'll see you next time